hi I'm Eric Voss and Game of Thrones is
on the brink of the most epic battle
sequence in TV history the Battle of
Winterfell with this next on Game of
Thrones trailer revealing once you
brighten this stuff so that we could see
anything some super subtle clues about
this coming night fight and since this
next episode is going to be so insane
I'm gonna break down this preview frame
by frame for all the details that you
might have missed explain the battle
strategy intricacies how those battle
intricacies will be thrown out the
window and who might not live to see the
Sun Rise spoiler warning the case I
accidentally predict anything you don't
want to know
let's take a look mr. right thing we can
do let's look the trees in the face
okay this teaser opens with the
unsullied all lined up facing the
darkness but brightening up this shot in
the upper left corner two dragons are
visible flying off this is presumably
Daenerys and John on drogon and regal
Daenerys and John appear in the later
shot overlooking the flanks on a nearby
hill last episode John told us that he's
holding back the two dragons to surprise
the knight King in bazarian when they
come for a branch in the godswood we
need to be named not too near the night
King won't come but close enough to
pursue him when he does Dragon Fire will
stop him I don't know no one's ever
tried donnas assuming that killing the
night king alone will Domino the entire
army of the Dead the way killing one
white Walker officer dominoed all the
white foot soldiers under that White
Walkers command but again John does have
a track record of no one nothing
illustrated by Arya and brand pointing
out that we don't even know if dragon
fire will kill the night king it may
require something else for example we
cyclical return to the night Kings
origin pinning him do a weirwood tree
stabbing him through the heart with
dragonglass among the Winterfell
defenses are catapults and trebuchets
which we military history nerds are very
insistent on reminding the world are not
the same thing there's also a shot of
Samwell Tarly the white Walker Slayer
watching the unsullied marching out to
formation I assume Sam will join the
defense's inside the castle walls this
episode will be directed by miguel
sapota nic director of the epic moments
like that all the bastards in hardhome
he and his production team watched the
Battle of Helm's Deep from Lord of the
Rings to two towers another nighttime
defensive battle with heavy
precipitation toggling among various
points of view to humanize this epic
battle on a more personal scale helms
deep was also fought in layers the
fortress battlements the inner castle
when those walls were breached and then
the further inner caverns where the more
vulnerable people hid in this case the
vulnerable are down in the Winterfell
crypts Varys Gilly young Sam and that
little northern girl in Davos med and
she reminded him Shireen Baratheon we
also know from a release photo that
Tyrion Lannister will join them down
there as well but but but as has been
speculated before these crypts might not
be the safest place to be the night King
resurrects the dead of which there are
plenty in these tombs even in the Stark
ancestors Deacon
States we have seen whites as bear
skeletons before in the books John
actually experiences a nightmare in
which the tombs of the Winterfell crypts
opened up in the stark kings of the past
rise so if this theorized threat from
within comes to pass it could be the
source of various concern as well as
Tyrians but let's move on to the second
half of this teaser the night king is
coming
the dead are already here okay John
whispers my king is coming but since we
haven't seen the night king or Vaziri on
in any of this footage for the Battle of
Winterfell it is possible that this is
again a misdirect audio from another
scene or another episode and the night
King is actually somewhere else like as
many have speculated the king could be
landing in King's Landing or my
preferred Theory burning down a Citadel
library in Old Town since bran revealed
that the night Kings true goal is to
erase human history from Westeros but
still there is a shot of John looking
out in terror at something in this
blizzard since the White Walkers are
using a winter storm to blind these
soldiers in a literal fog of war the
army of the Dead features plenty of
freakish Horrors resurrected zombie
bears and zombie Giants maybe we'll see
those legendary giant ice spiders that
old man used to scare us with and let's
talk about the full Winterfell defenses
comparing this to the battle map that we
saw in episode 2 we know that the
frontline is made up of Dothraki cavalry
I assume sir Jorah will be joining them
behind them is a line of trebuchet sand
catapults with fires lit implying that
they're going to be hurling flaming
artillery at the army of the Dead behind
that is the grid of the unsullied
infantry on the far left flank are the
Knights of the Vale which will be led by
Sir Brienne of Tarth joined by Podrick
and Jaime Lannister and the entire right
flank is made up of stark soldiers I'm
calling them stark soldiers because that
battle map labels them with a stark
direwolf sigil but this is really a
combined coalition of whatever was
remaining of the stark soldiers the wild
lanes and the northern families like the
Karstarks and the manderlys who
supported John after the battle the
bastards
I assume this right flank could be under
the command of tormund maybe John
himself though I could also see him
sticking with Dany and the dragons to
confront the night King along the walls
a trench has been dug filled with wooden
pikes that they plan to set ablaze a
moat of fire perhaps trying to thin the
herd of whites down to just the White
Walkers the battlements are armed with
archers commanded by Sir Davos and
dragon glass spiked logs to sweep across
like that safe that we saw along the
wall in season four inside the castle
the bear sigil of house Mormont is place
suggesting that Lyanna Mormont and her
small forces of house Vermont will guard
the castle interior we also know that
Theon Greyjoy and a small band of
Ironborn will guard the godswood and
bran the teaser actually shows be on air
with a flaming arrow nocked
actually this reminds me of a moment
with Theon in the same location all the
way back in the second episode of the
series remember rob wanted to avenge
brand and Theon backed him up once it
comes to that you know I'll stand behind
you
is there going to be a battle in the
godswood now theone is fulfilling his
promise to rob to defend brand with an
actual battle in the godswood arias
Sprint's through the halls of Winterfell
wounded on her head perhaps fleeing some
of these risen White's if that theory is
true or some that might have just
breached the walls there's also a shot a
beric Dondarrion with his flaming sword
in the hound with his new dragon glass
axe creeping around perhaps seeking some
same inner threats and there's a quick
shot of a dragon in the blizzard
but brightening this image it's clearly
not the night King on Vissarion it's
Daenerys writing drogon unsullied
soldiers raise their Spears and their
shields have been fused with dragonglass
lining and Jon unsheath Longclaw
his Valyrian steel sword there's a tree
behind him suggesting this could be in
the godswood and Jon is confronting the
night king one on one it's interesting
to realize that all the Valyrian steel
weapons that have been introduced on
this series have found their way to this
battle where they're obviously so
desperately needed Longclaw with Jon the
cat's paw dagger with Arya the Tarly
family sword Hart's name given by Sam to
Sir Jorah Brienne sword o keeper in
Jamie's sword widow's wail these two
were forged from melting down Ned
Stark's sword ice so now the twin swords
are symbolically fused back together to
reinvent Starks spirit Daenerys tells
John the dead already here perhaps
evidence of the crypt resurrection
theory that we talked about but it could
also be Daenerys finishing her argument
with John from earlier like maybe John
is defending his timing which admittedly
wasn't great saying he wanted to reveal
to Daenerys who he was before the Dead
arrived and she's like dude the dinner
already here remember she did tell Sansa
last episode that if anything she was
the one who felt manipulated by John to
fight in his war
and maybe now she's accusing John of
knowing who he really was the whole time
all time in using her fire power to
vanquish his enemies so that he could
claim to be the hero and claimed the
iron throne away from her last episodes
noble moments with characters like Sir
Jorah and grey worm put those two at the
top of my death pool I also don't feel
too great about Jaime Podrick tormund or
serine 2.0 comment down below with which
characters you think will die next
episode follow me on instagram and
twitter at EA boss and subscribe to new
rock stars for all of our Game of
Thrones coverage and again springy wood
tension catapult counterweight and sling
trippy shade that's right
[Music]